Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier...
and welcome to Breach and Clean!
The game where you're gonna
get that room clean!
No matter who gets in your way
You gotta blow your way into the room-
ooof...
You gotta put explosives on the door
and blast your way into the room
and then clean as fast as you're capable of doing
at least I think
The trailer for this game was a weird live action one
that was actually really cool so
I'm gonna go for it!
Weee!!
Okay I don't know how to play...
Hyea!
Oh shit!
What about that one?
No it's locked
How 'bout this one?
What am I doing with these goddamn towels?
Get outta my face!
I've got a room to clean!
Can I pull this?
No, it's a push only
NYEH!
HUH?
WHAT?
*person talking*
HWHAAAT?
what are you- what are ye- wha- eh!
I've got an attitude about that floatin' penis above your head!
OOOHHHH, I'M FIRED AM I?
Ohhh, shit, shit, shit!
FUCK you, and FUCK you!
Oh, just cause I intruded on someone masturbating
their giant floating dick above their head,
I get fired
Okay, whatever
Movin' on, movin' on, movin' on
Bam!
*Bad French accent* Uh, monsieur?
Hello?
*character gibberish*
Oh! Junk clising in the brunler!
Sorry, I did not know!
HOUSEKEEPING!
Housekeeping!
How bout- boink
AAHH
BOOM!
Hello?
ooooh
ugh
oh
UH-HUH
Ugh!
That's a lot of stains!
A lot of very questionable
*gibberish nonsense*
AAHH I'M SORRY!
I did not mean it!
No I didn't
Oh, I'm sorry
Imma just try to clean
*stutter*
I'm in here!
AAAHHH
Don't mind the explosions!
hueh!
Ok. You didn't see anything did ya?
I- I didn't see anything
J- Jun jini brunj quay?
What?
*character gibberish*
Blexic plung way?
Ok, that guy, that guy's busy
So let's try not that
How bout this one?
Ohh get outta my face!
Get outta my -GAHH
Get outta my face
There we go
Habiski!
Lemme get a good look a this one!
duh
Ooww!
My eyeballs exploded!
Okay
So I gotta
Get the trash
In the trish-can
Shit
I did it
*Singing* I~ GOTTA~ MOP~!
WAAAA!!
Good thing there was no one in here
Or else I would've been heavily disturbed
HOOOWWWAAA SHA
I'll put that there
Floating in the middle of my cart is the best place for that
HOW BOUT SOME HOT
FRESH
TOWELS!?
Bleh
Yeah, it's good enough
Pick up the can
*grunting*
Blam!
Done and done
Nice and clean
Oh god UGH!
What did they do to this thing?
UGH
Get outta here!
Ooh Nelly, good thing I got two replacements
for this
Habayama
Ok so the brown ones is the bad ones
Wabooski!
Ohh i'm the master of disaster
eh bloosh
Cleaning disaster, that is
All done! Eee!
How am I supposed to be able to get out-
This guy's an asshole! He's in there
Ohhh I guess I gotta put my
MMMMMMMM
I guess I gotta just deal with not having that clean then
I'm done! Take me home...
Why do I have mops floating in the middle of the hallway over there?
That doesn't seem logical
Monsuier? Do you need some toilet pya-pya?
Don quay?
AAHH
Don't mind me
Don't mind- ah shit
Don't do- AHHH
no (x5)
it okay (x3)
Huh
Jeezumz
*nonsensical singing*
S Sou?
S- S sou?
How boutta bomb for your bath?
It's called a bath bomb
every- it's all the rage
Sho bouaa
Da munkis grine?
I know, I know
Bomp guay
Bleth auu
Bless uup!
What did you break?
What did you break?! Eughh!
Planahay?
No (x5) It's fine (x3)
He don't remember a thing
Do you need anything in there?
Okay, I got that one
We're all good, I just left a few bombs around here
Alright, we're good
Let's get outta here
We did it
Alright!
First floor done,
with a bonus may- oh shit, another one
goddamit
Hello!
Housekeeping?
*gasp*
He's asleep
Well, now's my chance to murder him with a bomb!
OR MOP!
AAAHHH DON'T WAKE UP
Oh, just 'cause I was shouting as soon as you- eugh!
Well that's not mop worthy
That's not mop worthy at all!
Heh
Don't mind me!
Don't mind me sir
REEEEEEEEAAAAHHHH
boink
k
So I just gotta get- Reeueu oh shit
Just got- reueue shit
Just gotta- oh shit
AHHHH
There we go
Got it
SCUSE ME MONSUIER
I'm embarrasin' ? You're embarrasin'!
Hey wuppum quay?
Nah, I don't think so
Nah I only wuppum quay the best of 'em
And you can wuppum quay yourself
Oh whoa
Hello?
Oh god
Don't mind me
stealthy
eugh~
S' messy
Ugh so many stains!
Why so many stains?
What did you do?
Don't mind me (x2)
Okay I'll go in another door quick
Oh it's locked?
Well that ain't gonna stop me!
GOOOO!
AHHHHH
Oh there's no one in here
UGH
There's no one in here at all!
There's no need to rush
huh
Least I had fun
REEEEAAAAAAHHHH
BLOOSKY!
Not done?
Not done?!
What could possibly more need to be done?
Oh fuc- whoa
Guess I could drain 'em
AHHH there we go all done
Let's go home baby!
Get home
Ugh you can go faster than this
If I use my explosives
It would be so easy
Bam!
Done-zo!
Donion rings!
Oh, another one
Right here we go!
This one's gonna take some doin'
Alright
We got a double banger
Oh shit I didn't need to do that
We got triple banger apparently
because I feel extra explosive today
AAAAHHHHH
GOOOOOOO
AHHHHH
Oh there's no one in here again
Whoa
Shit sorry
Sorry bout that
I blasted him into oblivion
Do we have more moppage?
AGHHH
Anyone STAININ?
AHHHH
Gross stains bruh
How bout in here?
st- AHH SO MANY STAINS!
What's with the stains?
At least this one's done
Done
Flip that floppy
Don't mind me
*French accent* I hope you get blasted with esplosives
Sir you seem to have dropped- oh shit
Whoop that's a mistake
Wubbum quay indeed
I'm sorry was that me?
I apologize, were you trying to sleep?
Oh fuck you
Are you alright?
Can I- can I-
UHHH
*screaming*
Okay I'll come back to you later sir
3, 2, 1!
OOOOOYYYY
Hey there's no stains in here!
Oh sorry sir
You alright
Probably not
No no no no, no no no Don't worry
Sorry you seem to be suffering from a not exploding problem
Thau- Have a good night!
K what about the douche in here?
Was there a douche in here?
Bing bing bing!
Oh it's open!
WAHH!
And it's OH MY GOD
Oh I just gotta put an extra explosive on here just in case
eh
you slob
don't- don't mind me
Gotta go!
REAAHH!
AHHHH
Good enough
Good enough okay I'm outta here!
That's all I needed to do!
REAREAREA
Bam! Okay!
Heh
What I'm not done?
Not done?!
Oh what did this asshole need?
I don't know what he needs!
What does he need?!
Doesn't need anything
He doesn't need anything
It's a bunch of lies!
What an asshole
There's no- there's nothing to be done!
FUCK YOU MAN!
There's nothing to be done there's nothing else in here!
Goddamit there's nothing else in there
*INHALE*
And all of these are merely adequate
They're not perfect
But I'm not perfect
So mmmeh
Maybe there's some secret moppage going on
Oh really? (x2)
It just needed a slight
DAB of a mop
so that it would be done
I guess I'm done here
Okay screw you all
Screw you all!
WHY AM I NOT DONE?!
Do I gotta close the goddamn door?
Oh good night monsuier
Alright NOW I'm done
OHHHH COME ON
Did I not close this one?
HEEH
there we go now we're done!
m'kay we're good (x5)
Bam!
AH COME ON
I'm done!!
They're all adequate
I know they're not perfect
But they're adequate!
And I mean I like to pride myself in being adequate
not perfect OH NO
AHHH
Oh my toilet paper's spinning out of control- well
well sack of shit that I am
at least my thing caused a great big stain
for the next asshole that comes by and tries to clean your GODDAMN HOTEL!
*sigh*
Well either way that is Breach and Clean
and its oddly enough pretty fun
it reminds me of viscera cleanup detail
which I haven't played for a long time
but either way if you like games about janitorial duties
this one might be the one for you!
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always, I will see you
In the next video!
BUH-BYE!